concerning populism very important
things you identify populism in your
speech with right populism but there is
left populism in Europe for example chin
questell and five stars there or podium
modes or the how I said the left-right
division is series there is populism I
think that is very interesting and to
liberal tendency it's not only something
purely negative it's a kind of chance if
we will regard populism at something of
the old of the
resurgence of fascism or lefties most
aligned ISM and so on so it will grow we
need to understand it phenomena as
critical maybe it is the birth a new
form of critical theory not left no
right beyond left or right so I think
that populism represents in the United
States as well because the Trump is
populist President Putin is absolutely
populist but he is not right nor left
neither left nor left so I think the
populism in the United States in Russia
in Europe represents something more than
we are
we think maybe we will maybe educate
populism to speak with populist movement
to understand in instead of demonizing
it because now liberal this curse is
populism is growing that is new danger
which we should find the way how to
resist but maybe we need Toto to make a
kind of dialogue with populism so maybe
include and not exclude populism in our
democratic system that well I have to I
have to report to you I have to report
to you that in the United States at
least populism is the exact opposite of
critical thinking the exact you can't
wait wait wait populism in the United
States and elsewhere from what I read
but I know the populism where I live is
essentially the politics of emotion and
of high emotion and it places an almost
mystical faith in the wisdom of the
people now one of the things you kind of
wait wait wait wait no no no there's
nothing there's nothing whatsoever knew
about populism and there is nothing
whatsoever knew about the mystical faith
in the wisdom of the people these are
very old ideas and in my view very old
mistakes because one of the things that
history kabbalah tradition is the
greatest achievement of human spirit my
friend I have studied the Kabbalah my
whole life in the Hebrew language and
well and I'm here and I have to tell you
that it has absolutely nothing to do
with the wisdom of the people what
history show but mister what history
shows is that the wisdom of the people
frequently becomes justifications for
terrible crimes and that the what passes
as the wisdom of the people can lead
directly to evil and the American system
certainly when the founders of ours
wrote our Constitution
they considered populism they called it
they called it direct democracy and they
ruled it out in favor of representative
democracy
precisely so as to make possible
deliverer deliberation and rational
consideration of the issues facing the
country the fourth layer well it's so
far so good well no but I have to also
say at the point when we were discussing
the idea of democracy now
coming from Afghanistan we have been at
the graceful receiving end of American
democracy in the form of two disasterous
effect elections
and two presidents and a mafia system at
the end of the day there is very little
faith in the idea of what is American
democracy
it's been put into challenge as well in
Iraq for example
in the list of things that you started
and I agree with you in terms of going
back and trying to understand the
internal forces of this don't you think
it is also about time for us to go back
and understand what is the American
democratic political democratic system
and make a distinction because as well
being a Canadian our form of practice of
the democratic political system is
rather different and there are some
safeguards put in place against what
exactly you described in terms of the
takeover by the populace but in America
it is the force of the material the
powerful and the sort of capital economy
that has corrupted somehow the political
system in my view but I'd like to hear
what do you think internal forces
directly to things yeah first as an
Afghan you can thank both Russia and the
United States
North you per se but your your army
second and again I think Leon's exactly
right two things that are happening one
is we the system that was designed was
designed in order to favor deliberation
to avoid the passions of the moment but
for the reasons that I suggested earlier
we are now being overtaken by the
passions of the moment
the unbridled flow of information
creates so much pressure now on decision
makers to make decisions immediately to
just react to just do something to just
act that that process of deliberation is
taken away and that's one of the
greatest dangers I think that we face
but the truth of the matter is for all
of the challenges that we have now we
have self-correcting mechanisms and
we've gone through these periods
throughout our history we went through
McCarthyism we went we went through
McCarthyism we went through the 1960s in
the turmoil there we've gone through a
series of challenges a civil war but
these self-correcting mechanisms usually
ensure that once we've managed to get
everything wrong we eventually get it
right so right now we still have a
strong functioning independent media
that calls truth to power we still have
a strong functioning effective very very
courageous all in to deal with local
stories but not the same when it applies
to interests well no but so there's
another but I'm just saying in terms of
our own positions right and I still
believe in the resilience of those
systems despite the fact that
unfortunately we seem to have right now
a president who's taken a page out of
the book of other leaders in going after
those very sources that check the power
of anyone the power says it don't the
about the Dutch media in the United
States of America I
respectfully disagree with you because
nobody reads them or watches them
anymore it's no we know as a result that
Facebook took over and the mr. Putin
knew how to use Facebook to create
quote-unquote his his fake news and
Aleksandra listened and in the interview
you gave to our newspaper which by the
way is a very good newspaper and more
people should read it but
the you were in favor of getting Trump
into power and I cannot connect - Trump
in your view as president of the United
States of America we through idea that
that that every nation or civilization
will stick to its own idea why is it
that put in
certain way you did not leave America
alone you know why interfere in
elections so the only our dream that
America level on the world and
leave the world alone so if America will
concentrate as trap promised on itself
and will try to make it great again
inside that's the only only dream so we
could help America to be to return to
the greatness
without us without other world because
in Trump we have remarked the third
party he was anti-establishment
candidate oh he was a kind of trickster
going against traditional publicans
traditional Democrats and that was a
kind of voice of this silent majority of
American people that has chosen
something else that American elite
interventionist imperialist humanistic
at once so that was the hope for us
maybe after coming to the White House
where our it'll be disappointed by trap
but never delet we still hope because he
he tries now to understand where he is
so that is the first step and that is
promising something maybe he finally to
the end of his presidency he will well
understand something in the in the inner
and external politics but now
he has stopped at least negative agenda
of United States of America including in
the Middle East so I'm absolutely we are
grateful to mr. Trump because he has
left us a little bit alone for that was
precisely he was blamed for that by Livi
by Bernardo levy so I agree with his his
analysis but from the other point
I'll make you I'll make you easier even
from the United States yes exactly I'll
make you the deal the United States will
consider leaving the world alone when
Russia considers leaving the world alone
as an Afghan I would say please Russia
and please America leave the world alone
let me explain that when you get
involved no let me let me explain that
when the power and super powers get
involved in
proxy wars and in advancing their own
interests okay where is it Afghanistan
whether it's any of the other countries
around the world or whatever was it in
the 70s Latin America the problem with
that is if you want to help the Middle
East Afghanistan do it through
humanitarian help do it through medical
help do it through educational help but
leave your armies and militaries aside
because they create disastrous results
and we have seen it a few times we have
seen it repeated and I agree with a
previous debate earlier in the first
round table where the idea came about I
think it was Yvonne was it just because
we have advanced so technologically we
are under some kind of an illusion that
in terms of our
and advances we have also achieved
something great but I think there has
been a regression technologically a lot
of advancement has happened and we're
all talking about Facebook and the rest
of it but in terms of the development of
the humanists thought in terms of the
development of democracy in terms of the
development of even liberalism and the
idea of intervention and intervention we
are still a stuck in a century behind
and no further thinking and development
has happened unless we are really
willing to invest in that and bring our
humanist thinking and development of our
human thought to the level of our
technological and scientific achievement
the country's involvement in other
countries militarily are going to
produce more disasters and Afghanistan
is a particular case in a study and I
encourage people to go and actually look
at this history of the last 30 years
where I grew up in that war fought
against the Russians I was a radical
Islamist and I moved to the West and I'm
also skeptical of the American foreign
policy involved in all of the region so
as an outsider to both of these I would
say we need to rethink and reevaluate
internally our own system
you